furlough until september universal
credit uh
top up to continue for six months
minimum wage
increased you must be pretty pleased
with the budget
no i'm afraid i can't say that to you
mark so what we were crying out for
was first of all a budget that would be
a road map to recovery get people back
to work uh and as well as that i think
we need as a country to address
the long-term problems we've had going
into the into the pandemic
that have made the impact of the
pandemic in the uk so much more severe
insecurity
law pay uh child poverty all things that
have made it so much harder to tackle
now on the first of those things i
recognize what you're saying about
follow being
extended but of course fellow is about
protecting people still in jobs and
absolutely right
it is but we have now in the uk still a
huge problem with unemployment
even though furlough was still in place
you know unemployment hitting six and a
half percent as the chancellor said
that's over two million people and what
we've heard so far from the government
is not enough to get people
back to work and with that point around
universal credit
i've been campaigning and i make the
point it would have been unthinkable
for universal credit to be cut from the
beginning of next month
but what that means is now in october
you'll see the end of furlough where
you'd expect unemployment to rise
unemployment benefits then go to one of
their lowest levels for many many
decades in the uk
and at the same time there's other
support being removed so that's a really
difficult problem
and just on those long-term issues
market almost no mention of the nhs
no mention of schools and teachers
despite the massive educational
challenge we've got for people to catch
up because of the impact of the pandemic
there was nothing on sick pay even
though that's been a real barrier
to getting on top of the pandemic and
infections and nothing nothing that
gives you that ambition we're going to
stop being a country where we see those
queues of people outside food banks so
for me i think it is papering over the
cracks it's not ambitious enough and
it's just not enough for what the
country needs
yeah i know and i mean you know key
worker pay rises
is a strong case clearly social care
doing more on that is a strong case
clearly but how would you have paid for
all that stuff uh
you know the spending is massive as it
is what how would you have paid for all
the extra stuff you say he should have
done
well so you're right to say if we can't
get the government interested in social
care after a pandemic like this you do
wonder
if we ever will but be clear all the
government spending
in the main right now is coming from
increased borrowing and that is the
right response
in a recession the scale of which we are
experiencing because what we have to do
is get this country growing again get
people back to work that expands the tax
base
and that's how you get the economy more
sustainable debt levels more sustainable
in the longer term you have to shrink
the debt the country has incurred in the
pandemic
relative to the size of the economy and
that's the crucial point we can't tackle
any of this
unless we get people back to work and
growth happening
and things moving again and that's the
challenge that's what he's trying to do
i mean
just sorry to interrupt but i'm not
clear where would the burden be falling
you know in terms of tax if you wanted
to spend
more money on on social care and and pay
rises for
for for key workers you get it from
getting the economy growing from the
proceeds of that growth
being able to be spent by the government
and if you look at
you know what the government has set out
for me they just haven't learned the
lessons
of what the government did after the
financial crisis when they took over in
2010 where the
recovery was stalled and that made the
national finances so much harder to get
in control of you know going into this
pandemic we've had four or five years of
very low levels of growth
by historical standards we've had
terrible growth in productivity
which is what really generates the
revenue to invest in public services and
make things better
and that's the central challenge it's
getting the economy moving and growing
yes at this time it is the right time to
spend money
and that's the crucial thing if you not
just the universal credit card
the big increase in council tax for most
people across the country
because of the local government funding
situation all of this is not just bad
for families it's bad for the economy
overall